taken down under the cover of darkness
boards were erected around the monument
which was then covered up
eight meters tall the pillar of shame
depicts 50 torn and twisted bodies piled
on top of each other it symbolized lives
lost during the military crackdown on
pro-democracy protesters in beijing's
tiananmen square on june 4th 1989
but since october it had become an issue
of dispute
the university demanding it be taken
down in a statement they said
the decision on the age statue was based
on external legal advice and risk
assessment for the best interest of the
university they added the university is
also very concerned about the potential
safety issues resulting from the fragile
statue and just like that
it was taken away and put in storage
the hong kong alliance is gone the hong
kong university students union is also
gone and today even the pillar of shame
is gone
maybe they just want to erase our
memories of the 1989 tienem and crack
down
so we must preserve this memory and
fight against forgetting
in previous years students gathered on
june 4th to remember the events in
tiananmen square
but authorities have now banned them
citing concerns about the culvert 19
pandemic
clearly what the communist party wants
to impose here is a kind of amnesia
about what happened in china more than
30 years ago
[Applause]
the move follows a controversial
national security law in hong kong last
year that outlaws succession subversion
terrorism and foreign collusion to
intervene in the city's affairs
it sparked protests and criticism of
beijing for curtailing freedoms that
were promised to hong kong when it was
handed back to china by britain in 1997.
for now there is an empty space where
the monument once stood but for many
even though the pillar of shame has been
removed the memory of what took place
cannot be erased assad begged al jazeera
okay let's bring in jens gulshirt who is
the sculptor of the pillar of shame and
joins us from denmark thanks for being
on the newshour yens before we get to
your reaction on the destruction of the
statue i'd really like you to talk us
through the significance of this work
for you and what you were trying to
convey when you were creating it
yes i created for about 25 years ago to
make a memory about something the
government don't want to memory
and
then i put it in hong kong together with
the chinese democracy movement and then
just before china china took over in
hong kong and this was the only
possibility to get a monument about the
cinnamon crackdown in 89 inside china
so to china take over in hong kong and
take hong kong uh into the country and
the pillar of shame
so
since then uh hong kong mainland china
has will be really angry on the monument
and trying
so
this is a 50
parties who are uh this is a test
monument this is a monument about the
death
uh and what happened in
this sculpture belongs to you personally
and it was loaned to the university so
what do you make of its removal and
potential destruction
this
is a really strange case and i think
it's a kind of attack against fairness
because i
offer them for two months three months i
have offered them to a bull by lawyer
and offer them a lot of latest and we're
in a lot of press and we are saying we
will go down to take it down and
keep it away and put it back to europe
without problem and then uh here in the
middle of nowhere two days before
christmas in the darkness they
make a lot of there was 50 cars around
it
and a lot of construction workers and i
think this is not really not fair to do
this kind of thing this is a
this is a brutal way to do that
are you concerned about the damage to
the sculpture as well
yes i have to take a look on the video i
have seen and i can see a big part of
the sculpture is still intact in some
way i can't see the uh this is a single
part of this culture but i'm quite sure
this is not able to do
to take it down on this way they do that
uh without demonstrating so of course
there is a lot of damage on the
sculpture and this is a problem because
it's my prophecy of
private prophecy and i there is some
rule about that so i think the hong kong
university and make a crime we take it
down
the private property of a foreign artist
so i think they have a big problem with
doing that
yes the university says the decision was
based on external legal advice and risk
assessment do you not see those as valid
reasons for its removal
i think
they they have as they have broken
some excuse this is not secure to help
this culture it is not right we have uh
technical uh
people who have taken a look at that i
have been there for
eight years ago to repair it so there's
no problem at all and and
we have a permission to stay there
and now they come to say okay you
haven't permission to stay there but we
have been there for 25 years
they have they have
making a ground
of cement and
concrete and all this kind of thing
and now they say you have a lot of
permission to stay there of course we
have a permission so this
this case and this will do they will
making attack against the democracy
movement
against freedom of expression in hong
kong this is what it is about
they will say you was not allowed to say
nothing
like the communist party in china is
against don't say nothing about the
german don't say nothing about young
doors nothing about the muslims
of china so this is the reason to do
that i think
well it will be interesting to see how
this story unfolds in the coming weeks
and months thank you for taking the time
to speak to us on this newshour jen's
goal shirt the sculpture of the pillar
of shame thank you
thank you